thanks doll in this modern age of ours
we are privileged to have many creature
comforts allotted by science and
technology comforts like the icebox
penicillin and atomic power but there's
one creature that isn't comfortable at
all
that's right it's the familiar war of
Godzilla the king of the monsters I'm
scared
whoa there chin up little wooden
Godzilla may be able to lay waste the
thousands within seconds but you don't
have to fear so Bible is possible and
really quite simple
this is Godzilla an amphibious reptile
bestowed with the power of the atham at
over three hundred and fifty feet tall
Godzilla's no pixie and it's Foreman
will strength an insatiable appetite for
destruction means it must always be
ready for danger tidal waves generally
marked the first arrival of Godzilla so
if you live by the sea you'll need to be
prepared a snorkel fins and float bags
are a surefire way to stay out of harm's
way
Godzilla's arrival all but guarantees
the complete destruction of your city so
you'll need to be prepared for debris
but before you say gee I think it's time
to skip town remember this deserting
your city means Godzilla has already won
and makes you a communist you aren't a
communist right right good I didn't
think so now let's practice what to do
if you find yourself surrounded by
falling buildings now Timmy ducking and
covering is how you survive the bomb you
need a more effective plan that will
protect at all costs get a pillow that's
like they always say a pillow on your
back is the best plan of attack
now that you're ready for debris you'll
need to prepare for Godzilla's greatest
strength and deadly assassin his atomic
blasts observe the atomic core this
seemingly infinite well of energy powers
a super concentrated beam of nuclear
radiation but although it looks like
candy it can burn you very badly much
like a sunburn but more dead sun paste
is the best defense in the event of an
attack also wear a hat it will keep your
brain from boiling timmy is prepared he
knows what to do in the event of a
Godzilla attack and that could mean the
difference between life and death
just remember your training and always
be prepared however if you do ever come
face to face with Godzilla there is one
thing you can do
run-run till you please save no one but
yourself
[Applause]
[Music]